go
sorry Canada recently banned Tick-Tock
on government devices
knowing what you know
are you comfortable with the idea of
your children or family members using
Tick Tock thank you
I've responded to the question first
here well first of all look uh in 10
years Russia and and China have had 40
meetings
40 millions and I disagree with the
basic premise of your question
I have we have
you know significantly expanded our
alliances I haven't seen that happen
with China and or Russia or anybody else
in the world we're in a situation in the
United States where NATO is stronger
we're all together the G7
quad the uh asean Japan and Korea I have
uh my staff point out to me I have now
met with 80 percent of the world leaders
just since I've been president
we're the ones expanding the alliances
opposition is not name for me where
that's going
and tell me what hat I don't mean to
literally that but rhetorically tell me
how in fact you see a circumstance where
China has made some significant
commitment to Russia
and what commitment can they make
economically economically
that
pardon me their trade is increased sir
if the trades increase compared to what
look look I I don't take China lightly I
don't take Russia lately but I think we
vastly exaggerate I would hear I've been
hearing now for the past three months
how about China is going to provide
significant weapons to Russia and
they're going to they're all been
talking about that
they haven't yet doesn't mean they won't
but they haven't yet and if anything's
happened the West has coalesced
significantly more
how about the quad how about Japan and
the United States and South Korea how
about what we've done in terms of August
how about we I mean so I I just want to
put in perspective I don't take it
lightly what Japan what China excuse me
and uh and Russia are doing and it could
get significantly worse
but let's put into perspective
we are uniting coalitions we
we the United States and Canada
on Tick Tock uh we made a similar
decision to the American government and
others when we said that we do not feel
that the security profile is a safe for
government-issued phones there are
concerns around privacy and security and
that me that is why we have banned Tick
Tock from government issued phones
but your question Josh was about what I
do as a parent of teenagers and my kids
on social media and on that
on that uh I am obviously concerned with
the privacy and their security which is
why I'm glad that on their
phones that happen to be issued by the
government they no longer access Tick
Tock uh that was a big frustration for
them really this applies to us too Dad
yes I just did that
um
but I think as parents we are
understanding particularly of teenagers
just how much of our kids lives are
lived online
and how much they are impacted not just
by influence the way their friends are
and peer pressure that all of us went
through as teenagers
but a degree of misinformation
disinformation and malicious activity
that is allowed for by incredible
advances in technology that we are
benefiting from in so many different
ways
as governments we have to make sure
we're doing what we can to keep people
safe in the Public Square making sure
we're pushing back against hate speech
and incitations to violence online and
we're carefully calibrating legislation
to do that
a parent
spend a lot of time talking to my kids
about what's online and how they should
try and you know go outside and play a
little more Sports and not get so
wrapped up in their phones and we're
going to continue to do that our
concerns around tick tock are around
security and access to information that
the Chinese government could have to
government phones
it's just a personal side benefit that
my kids can't use tick tock anymore that
I recommend everyone to use my in my
encouragement to try and do
so few
what have we offered to the US in
exchange
for a long time
the agreement
you couldn't simply shut down Roxanne
and hope that everything would resolve
itself
and so that's why
we chose to modernize
agreement
so that someone who attempts to cross
between official Crossings
will be subject to the principle
Principle as someone who should receive
asylum in the first safe country they
arrived now for people who are coming
from the U.S
[Music]
with respect to Asylum Seekers
at the same time
the number of Asylum Seekers who we
accept
from the hemisphere Western hemisphere
in order to compensate
foreclosing these irregular Crossings
thank you Mr President this question is
for you
please feel free to answer as well um
killer Canada are you disappointed that
Canada is not partner hasn't taken a
bigger role in the multilateral forces
in Haiti and what would you like Canada
to do more in addition to the 100
million dollars announced today well no
I'm not disappointed look this is a very
very difficult Circumstance the idea of
how do we deal with what's going on in
Haiti where gangs have essentially uh
um taken the place of the government in
effect they run they rule the roost as
the saying goes and uh so I think that
what the Prime Minister has spoken about
makes a lot of sense the biggest thing
we could do and it's going to take time
is to increase the prospect of the
police departments in Haiti having the
capacity to deal with the problems
they're faced
and that is going to take a little bit
of time we also are looking at whether
or not the International Community
through the United Nations could play a
larger role in this event in this this
circumstance but there is no question
that there is a real genuine concern
because there are
several million people in Haiti and the
the uh the diaspora could cause some
real uh real uh how can I say it
confusion in the Western Hemisphere and
so but I think that what the Prime
Minister suggested and we are as well
going to be contributing to see if we
can both increase the efficiency and
capacity of the training and the methods
used by the police department as well as
16 if we can engage other people in the
hemisphere which we've been talking to
and they're prepared to do some so it's
a it's this work in progress
deputy
yourself
to try to stabilize the country
until the situation
bringing more peace and security and
stability
this won't happen tomorrow
at the same time part of the insecurity
and instability
from the misery of the Haitian people
for their own political gain their own
personal gain
and this is prevented the country from
recovering and that's why we're
proceeding with sanctions
to bring pressure
the political class
to hold them
for the distress facing the Asian people
but to hold them accountable for
ensuring their well-being we're going to
continue to work together we fully
understand
how important this task is Mr President
follow up with one point on Katie and
that is that any decision about military
force was often raised
we think would have to be done in
consultation with the United Nations and
uh and with the Haitian government and
so that is not off the table but that is
not in play at the moment
I'm sorry
over to you for the question Mr
President uh I uh Jordan uh you have a
question
thank you Mr President
um someone Wall Street have expressed
frustration that it's unclear what more
your Administration is willing to do to
resolve the banking crisis the markets
have remained in turmoil so how
confident are you that the problem is
contained and if it spreads what
measures such as guarantee more deposits
are you willing or not willing to take
first of all have you ever known Wall
Street not in consternation
number one uh look I think we've done a
pretty damn good job
people's savings are secure
and even those beyond the 250 000 of the
FDIC is guaranteeing the American
taxpayer is not going to have to pay a
penny
the banks are in pretty good shape
what's going on in Europe isn't a direct
consequence of what's happening in the
United States
and uh I uh what we would do is if we
find that is more instability than a
peers we'd be in a position to have the
FDIC use the power it has to guarantee
those those loans above 250 like they
did already
and so I think it's going to take a
little while for things to just calm
down but I don't see anything that's on
the horizon it's about to explode but I
I I do understand there's an unease
about this and these mid-sized banks
have to be able to survive and I think
they'll be able to do that
and Mr Prime Minister uh the U.S has
included Canada in an electric vehicle
subsidies as you've discussed uh that
were included in the inflation reduction
act but the IRA also raises some
competitiveness concerns and challenges
for Canada you know President Biden
supports by American Provisions very
strongly and that has historically led
to some trade tension so
um are you planning to announce anything
in your budget to keep up so to speak
and are you asking the US government for
exceptions to the buy American
Provisions in other areas
first of all there's nothing new about
Canada having to make sure that we
remain competitive with the United
States as a place for investment that's
something that we have long known as a
friendly competition between us that has
led to tremendous growth and benefits in
both of our countries
right now we're in a time where Joe
talked about it as an inflection point I
think that's exactly right
we can feel
the global economy shifting shifting in
very real ways towards lower carbon
emission Technologies
cleaner Tech
great jobs in the natural resource and
Manufacturing industries that are going
to be increased
on our continent after years of
Outsourcing and offshoring
there is a real opportunity for both of
us in the ira which is bringing in
massive Investments and massive
opportunities for American workers and
companies is also going to have strong
impacts on Supply chains and producers
and employees in Canada yes we're going
to have to make sure we're staying
competitive
and targeting the areas where we think
we can best compete and we'll have more
to say about that in our budget next
week
but let us take a moment to step back
and see that North America Canada and
the United States in particular are
incredibly well positioned
to be
the purveyors of solutions
and economic growth
that the Net Zero economy around the
world will need over the coming decades
The Innovation the know-how the ability
of us to make big things together
leave us in a time of global uncertainty
extremely certain
that we are well placed for the future
whether it's Investments that have seen
Canada go from fifth or sixth in the
world and turn up in terms of battery
supply chains to now second in the world
in terms of battery supply chains
whether it's continuing our leadership
on the cleanest aluminum in the world
moving towards cleaner Steel
and zero emission Steel
whether it's moving forward on critical
minerals that the world is understanding
they can no longer rely on places like
China or Russia for
that they can rely on Canada to be not
just a purveyor of oars but of finished
materials that will be built in
environmentally responsible Union or
good middle class jobs
wages
strong communities
and the kind of leadership that the
world is increasingly looking for
there's long been a bit of a
weakness I think to our argument that
we've made over the past decades as
Western democracies that says that our
model is the best one it leads to the
most Prosperity but so much of our model
we sort of turned our back to the fact
that it relied
on cheap Imports of
Goods or resources from parts of the
world that didn't share our values and
weren't responsible on the environment
or on human rights or on labor standards
and what we are doing right now is
showing
that we can and will
build resilient Supply chains between us
and with friends around the world
that adhere every step of the way
to the values that we live by
that make sure that there are good jobs
for workers and communities urban and
rural right across our continent
there are good careers for kids long
into the future not in spite of a
changing world but because of that
changing world and how well we are
positioned to see the future and meet
the future
that's why it's so exciting to be able
to work alongside Joe in these
challenging times
where we know we are better positioned
than just about anyone else and those
friends of ours who share our values and
our democracies around the world
will benefit from the strength and the
relations they have with us and those
who choose to continue to turn their
backs on the environment about human
rights
on the values of freedom and dignity for
all
will increasingly not be able to benefit
from the growth that our societies that
our communities are creating every
single day
by the way we have with the other needs
reach out with other needs
the idea that somehow Canada is somehow
a put a disadvantage because we're going
to probably be investing billions of
dollars
in their ability to package what is
coming out of the semiconductor area I
don't get it
how's that in any way do anything other
than hire and bring billions of dollars
into Canada
I also don't understand how when we talk
about it we we greatly need Canada in
terms of the minerals that are needed
well you guys we don't have the minerals
to mine you can mine them you don't want
to produce I mean you know turn them
into product
we do
I mean it's I I'm a little confused at
least thus far on why this is a
disadvantage for uh for Canada and the
United States I think we each have with
the other needs and let me conclude by
saying you know
when I started talking about we're going
to build our economies
from the middle out and the bottom up
not the top down
I was being literal
because what happened is if you think
about it in Democrat and Republican
administrations beginning
over 30 years ago or more in the United
States
Corporate America decided that they're
going to do is they're going to export
jobs and import product
because there's cheaper labor
well guess what now we are making sure
they import jobs
here jobs here
and we export product Ken is doing the
same thing
so this is a real this is a real shift
in the world economy in terms of what
we're prepared to do
and I'll be darned if I'm going to stick
in a situation where as long as I'm
president where we have to rely on a
supply chain in the other end of the
world that is affected by politics
pandemics or anything else
we're not tired we're not hurting anyone
in terms of having access to the start
of the supply chain
it's available but again
I I predict to you you're going to see
after we're both out of office both
China and China out of the game in terms
of many of the product that they're
producing and the United States and
Canada pretty solid economically
situated for the future in terms of also
bringing back manufacturing jobs
sorry
and they're telling me I'm talking too
long because we got to go to dinner
thank you
they will take one last question
uh my first question is for the Prime
Minister but Mr President feel free to
weigh in before my follow-up uh prime
minister we know you've we know that
you've appointed a special report or but
with what we've learned about Han Dong's
communication with the Chinese Consular
General do you believe he advocated for
the delayed release of the two Michaels
first of all Han gave a strong speech in
the house that I recommend people uh
listen to and we fully accept that he is
stepping away from the liberal caucus in
order to vigorously contest these
allegations
but I I do want to take a step back
and point out that foreign interference
interference by authoritarian
governments like China Russia
Iran and others
is a very real challenge to our
democracies and is absolutely
unacceptable
it's why over the past number of years
the president and I have had many
conversations about this and indeed
will continue to work together with our
Democratic allies around the world to
keep our institutions and our
democracies safe from foreign
interference in 2018 when Canada hosted
the G7 in we actually created the G7
rapid response mechanism to protect our
democracies in cases of interference
and we will continue to work together to
make sure we're doing everything
necessary
to protect our democracies which by
definition
are more open
and therefore more vulnerable
before an actress trying to weigh in
in our politics in our business in our
research institutions and particularly
impact on citizens themselves which is
why over the past years Canada like
our allies around the world has given
itself new
rigorous tools to counter for an
interference
and with the work that our expert
rapporteur will do with the work that
our national
security Committee of parliamentarians
will be doing and other institutions
we will continue to do everything
necessary to keep Canadians safe
nothing there
thank you and Mr President when you took
office you canceled the Keystone Excel
pipeline this week your government
delayed the environmental assessment to
rewrote Enbridge line five and at the
same time you're approving oil drilling
in Alaska so what's your response to
people who say it's hypocritical to
steiny Canadian energy projects while
allowing your own
first of all uh I don't think it is but
I'll be very brief
the difficult decision was on
what we do with the willow project in
Alaska
and my strong inclination was to
disapprove of it across the board
but the advice I got from Council was
that if that were the case I may very
well lose in court
and lose that case in court to the oil
company and then not be able to do what
I really want to do beyond that
and that is conserve significant amounts
of Alaskan sea and land forever
I was able to see two of the week
literally able to conserve millions of
Acres not a few millions of Acres of sea
and land forever so it cannot be used in
the future
I am banking on we'll find out that the
oil company is going to say not that's
not going to be challenged and they're
going to go with with three sites
and the energy that's going to be
produced there estimated would would
account to one percent one percent of
the total production of oil in the world
and so I thought it was a good a the
better Gamble and a hell of a trade-off
to have the Arctic Ocean the Bering Sea
and so many other places off limits
forever now
I think we put more land and
conservation than any Administration
since Teddy Roosevelt well not positive
with that but I think that's true
thank you all this is what concludes
today's press conference is
thank you
that's fine
[Music]
thank you